SEE HOW TRUMP VOTERS ARE
RESPONDING TO THE HEARINGS AND
HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
>> Reporter: PARADES.
FAMILY FUN.
PLENTY OF FLAGS ON DISPLAY ON
INDEPENDENCE DAY IN SARASOTA
COUNTY, BUT THIS IS TRUMP
COUNTRY SO THE STARS AND STRIPES
NOT THE ONLY FLAG FLYING.
>> WE'RE AT A TRUMP RALLY.
>> Reporter: JOSEPH BUSH IS A
TRUMP FAN.
THE 58-YEAR-OLD REPUBLICAN WHO
MOVED TO FLORIDA LAST YEAR LIKES
THAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT RAN
THE COUNTRY LIKE A BUSINESS.
>> THERE IS SOMEBODY THAT
BELIEVES IN OUR SECOND AMENDMENT
RIGHTS.
THE FLAG.
THE ECONOMY.
>> Reporter: TRUMP IS AS STRONG
AS EVER, HE SAYS, IN GOOD
STANDING TO LEAD THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY DESPITE THE REVELATIONS
EMERGING FROM THE JANUARY 6th
HEARINGS.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID SOMETHING
TO THE EFFECT OF, I'M THE F-ING
PRESIDENT.
TAKE ME UP TO THE CAPITOL NOW.
>> I WATCHED A LITTLE BIT OF IT
TO KNOW IT'S VERY ONE SIDED AND
IT'S DISTRACTION.
>> Reporter: SOMETHING WE HEARD
REPEATEDLY.
ARE YOU WATCHING THE JANUARY 6
HEARINGS?
>> I HAVE NOT.
>> Reporter: WHY?
>> I HAVEN'T GOT A CHANCE.
>> I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
VALIDITY TO WHAT'S HAPPENING.
ALSO A FISHING EXPEDITION.
>> IT'S NOT A HEARING.
IT'S A SHOW.
>> Reporter: WHILE SOME
REPUBLICANS AND INDEPENDENTS
HERE TOLD US THEY QUESTION THE
POLITICS BEHIND THE HEARINGS,
OTHERS --
>> I THINK WE NEED TO KNOW THAT
INFORMATION.
PEOPLE ARE NOT WELL INFORMED.
>> Reporter: IRINA IS WATCHING
THE HEARINGS.
SHE ONCE CONSIDERED HERSELF A
REPUBLICAN.
NOW --
>> I DON'T THINK THE TRUMP
MOVEMENT IS THE RIGHT MOVEMENT
FOR OUR COUNTRY.
I'D LIKE TO SEE A MORE MODERATE
REPUBLICAN.
>> Reporter: FOR LaROSE, RON
DeSANTIS IS NOT AN ALL TERNTIVE.
EVEN AS THEY APPEAR TO BE ON A
COLLISION COURSE, BOTH ARE POWER
HOUSE FUNDRAISERS AND WHILE
TRUMP REMAINS POPULAR WITH THE
GOP BASE, THERE ARE SOME SIGNS
DeSANTIS IS MAKING GAIN, PULLING
EVEN WITH TRUMP IN A RECENT NEW
HAMPSHIRE POLL OF VOTERS.
WHILE LOYALTY TO TRUMP HERE
REMAINS ON FULL DISPLAY --
>> I THINK TRUMP IS GOING TO
LEAD THE WAY.
HE NEEDS TO REDEEM HIMSELF FOR
SURE.
>> Reporter: REPUBLICANS ALSO
TOLD US THEY ARE OPEN TO A FRESH
FACE LEADING THE PARTY.
>> I DON'T THINK TRUMP WILL BE
ELECTED PRESIDENT AGAIN.
>> Reporter: WHY DO YOU SAY
THAT?
>> BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH, MANY
PEOPLE AGAINST HIM.